précédemment sur dtc 27 octobre 2018
après une rencontre cocasses et inopinés
je prends une décision
j'ai décidé cette fois de me faire
refaire les lits novembre 2018 je lance
l'opération ravalement de façade
ah ben je sors de chez le dentiste
justement le programme ça va être pour
la dans la - cas c'est une facette et
pour la dent la plus casse et une
couronne une prothèse de couronnes
dentaires et elle a accepté de me faire
un petit quelque chose de temporaire une
petite réparation un peu à l'arraché
avec du composite cédant 7 novembre 2018
l'aventuré prend fin voici toute
l'histoire
[Musique]
voilà début de l'opération
reconstruction c'est aujourd'hui les
choses sérieuses commencent maintenant
j'ai pas si vous vous souvenez la
dernière fois je vous avais dit que la
dentiste m'a fait vraiment du bricolage
pas dire qu'elles avaient collé des
bouts de de composites pourra me faire
des trucs très temporaire on attend une
semaine elle avait peu d'espoir que ça
tienne avec sa tenue donc ça c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
aujourd'hui le programme c'est que a
priori elle doit me retirer ça me
tailler les dents pour les préparer à
recevoir la couronne d'un côté la
facette de l'autre ensuite prendre mais
prendre mes empreintes pour voir à quoi
va devoir ressembler la prothèse qu'elle
va qu'elle va mettre ensuite elle en
verra tout ça et quand elle reçoit med
en définitive c'est à dire normalement
dans une semaine
j'y retourne t elle elle me met tout ça
j'anticipe le fait que je vais avoir une
anesthésie les fin de matinée du coup je
vais manger avant ce que j'ai vraiment
très peur à près de bavay beaucoup ne
pas trop être capable de de manger
notamment de déglutir sans faire une
fausse route c'est à dire sans que le la
nourriture passes dans le trou du
respirer au lieu de deux trous du manger
donc je vais manger un petit truc léger
parce que je pense d'eux de dégueuler
sur la dentiste après je vais me brosser
les dents évidemment ne serait ce que
par respect et puis parisienne et puis
je me mets en route et je vous raconte
après un petit conseil aussi fait pipi
avant de partir parce que ça peut ça
peut être long et prenez de quoi vous
occuper dans la salle d'attenté parce
que ça peut être lui aussi ses multiples
ips
voilà c'est fait
alors j'en reviens à l'instant j'ai pas
pu filmer sur place évidemment je parle
bizarrement parce que j'ai la lèvre
supérieure encore endormis et les
narines
ce qui est assez désagréable mais bon je
pense qu'il vaut mieux je vous raconte
ça un petit peu plus tard du coup quand
j'aurai récupéré à usage de tout mon
visage
jouant juste le truc très temporaire
camani qui va durer une semaine
voilà c'est un peu dégueulasse un but
comme ça il reste plein de il reste
plein de bouts de colles etc qui vont
qui devrait en tout cas me l'a promis
partir avec la salive rapidement donc je
vous je me remets et je vous raconte
tout ça plus tard bon j'ai laissé passer
24 heures écoutez fun fact regardez ce
qui s'est passé ce matin pendant que je
me brosser les dents
j'ai perdu la face est provisoire que
l'attentisme admis que la donc voilà il
m'avait prévenu que ça risquait pas
tenir que c'était encore plus fragile
que le truc provisoire canal et demi la
dernière fois qu était déjà fragile elle
m'a pas menti ça n'a pas tenu et donc
pour vous raconter un petit peu comment
ça s'est passé
contrairement à ce que je craignais j'ai
pas attendu du tout mais ça c'est un
détail j'ai été pris à l'heure ensuite
la la dentiste à préparer le terrain
pour la prochaine fois dans une semaine
c'est à dire qu'elle a pris mes
empreintes dentaires ham a fait mordre
dans une espèce de grosse patte qui
solidifie ensuite et qui prend
l'empreinte de médan donc avant
de les avoir préparés ensuite elle a
retiré donc les trucs temporaire qu'elle
fait là la fois précédente et elle a
taillé les deux ans six iep supérieur
c'est-à-dire les deux dents qui était
cassée prier ici
voilà sept ans n'a pas sa forme
naturelle elle les a taillé pour quoi
elle les a taillé pour qu'elle ait une
forme le plus géométriques en tout entre
guillemets possible et le plus lisse les
alpes au lit aussi pour pouvoir de fixer
dessus ensuite le la prothèse
deux couronnes dentaires ici et là face
est ici l'idée c'est que la surface qui
va recevoir la facette et la prothèse
soit le plus lisse et le plus carré
possible histoire qui pas possible dans
leur besace s'applique bien et ensuite
qu'il n'y a pas possibilité qui est des
cochonneries qui s'infiltrent ensuite
parce que s'il ya des petites aspérités
il ya toujours le risque qui est pas
vraiment de la colle partout et c'est
donc qu'il y ait des petites des petits
trucs qui s'infiltrent donc une fois
quel mal taillée et limer les dents
voyez ici
avant c'était cas c'est déjà un petit
bout qui avait sauté là il ya plus donc
quand elle m'a bien taillé et poli
les dents et aidera elle m'a refait des
empreintes dentaires en haut et en bas
qui vont servir de base pour préparer la
facette et la prothèse ensuite elle a
regardé la teinte de médan cale à noter
pour que la prothèse soit pas ultra
grand blanche alors que j'ai pas les
dents blanchies sim donc voilà elle
transmet toutes ces informations au
prothésiste dentaire qui va fabriquer
mes dents et il est vrai de la bonne
forme pour que ça se mette bien dans la
bouche à l'extérieur de la bonne forme à
l'intérieur pour que ça se mette bien
sur l'île ce qui reste de mes dents et
de la bonne teinte celle que lui a
transmise la dentiste pour que ça
détonne pas dans le dans la bouche
donc ça a duré moi je dirais quand même
une bonne demi-heure voire 40 minutes
bah après ça vous connaissez anesthésie
évidemment donc petite piqûre dans le
dos de la gencive là comme vous l'avez
vu ça endort la bouche ça endort les
dents ça c'est plutôt bien fait en
dehors le nez voilà bouche ouverte la
salive dans le fond les machins le truc
il gicle partout et cetera vous
connaissez mes 0 douleur sur le coup et
mon petit conseil perso la dentiste m'a
prescrit des médicaments anti douleur
pour après la séance en me disant si
quand la neste dit se lève
vous sentez que vous commencez à avoir
mal prenez un médicament contre la
douleur
mon petit conseil perso dans ces cas là
attendez pas que l'anesthésiste ça se
réveille prenez un antidouleur
systématiquement au mois les 24
premières heures
alors selon la prescription à celle ci
pas de faire n'importe quoi juste c'est
toujours plus facile de combattre la
douleur quand on te laddh tu avant
qu'elles apparaissent vraiment donc vous
rentrez chez vous prenait un comprimé de
ce que vous aura prescrit le médecin et
puis bah plus tard je sais pas si c'est
tous les quatre heures ou toutes les six
heures bal à quatre ou six heures plus
tard reprenant 1 est comme ça jusqu'au
lendemain
éventuellement le lendemain vous
attendez de voir si vous avez mal faut
prendre ou pas mais bon moi je dirais
dans la première journée attendait pas
d'avoir mal pour prendre des
antidouleurs montpetit cas personnel du
coup bah je me retrouve avec la facette
en moins c'est douloureux parce que je
me suis fait polir la dent est de
nouveau sensible comme immédiatement
après que ça a été cassé je vais appeler
pour voir s'il faut que je revienne si
c'est embêtant si ça risque d'abîmer la
surface qu'elle a calé bien préparé donc
s'il faut que j'y retourne pour qu'elle
me remettre quelque chose je ne sais pas
encore je verrai est mort voilà 24
heures plus tard j'ai appelé la dentiste
elle m'a dit qu'elle préférait quand
même que je passe pour me remettre un
truc parce que la dent avait quand même
été pas mal taillée du coup elle était
très fine ce qui en plus d'être un peu
le moche mais ça garde présentait trois
inconvénients
d'abord c'était quand même pas mal
sensible au chaud au froid au toucher
notamment et c'est ensuite
bah ça s'était très coupants donc ça
munich est un peu les lèvres et la
langue et surtout plus embêtant ça
risquait de se péter ou de se fissurer
où elle a du coup comme à la lève tout
préparé pour recevoir la semaine
prochaine ma dent définitif à la face
est définitive si ça s'était pété il
aurait fallu tout recommencer donc ça
aura été vraiment cher donc du coup elle
m'a remis un truc que temporaire donc
c'est toujours pas bouffer mais ça fait
le lassent pas de job pour quelques
jours et ce coup là est là à changer de
technique de fixation faut pas que ça
tienne ou trop bien parce que même leurs
tirs et bientôt donc il s'ajuste pas que
quelle galère mais bon la même manière
un truc qui tient un peu mieux et
surtout elle a bloqué les deux grands
ensembles avec du composite qu'elle-même
derrière du coup j'ai un peu
l'impression alsei comme quand on mange
à un gâteau un gâteau un peu mou et
qu'il ya un gros paquet qui se collent
entre le palais dans la ba voila j'ai
l'impression d'avoir ça en permanence
est bon ça me fait encore plus deux
autres que d'habitude et surtout j'ai
tendance à enfin ma langue a tendance à
rebuter dessus j'ai envie de toucher de
jouer avec et tout et vaut mieux pas
sinon ça va retomber dedans que ça
d'après de bonnes idées mais voilà tout
est bien qui finit bien j'ai plus mal ça
ne coûte plus ça me coupe la langue ça
me coupe les lèvres et surtout bat
normalement si ça reste comme ça le week
end puisque le week-end approche ce sera
bon pour le début de semaine prochaine
voilà allez à bientôt voilà ça y est le
week-end est passé on se retrouve dans
quelques jours plus tard depuis
plus contaminés on m'a remis sept postes
dans temporaire et aujourd'hui c'est le
jour du des gros travaux
c'est à dire que c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
va mettre à les dents définitives donc
la bonne nouvelle fait que à part ici un
petit truc péter et avant le gros
morceau de mie de pain derrière d'armé
dans qu'ils m'empêchent de fermer la
bouche correctement et de parler de
façon fluide voit tout s'est bien passé
ça a tenu donc cool aujourd'hui débat
c'est le grand jour
j'y vais je vous raconte après croiser
les doigts pour moi voilà donc alors
première chose il neige un petit peu un
jeu je sais pas si vous êtes twitter je
me suis dit au courant mais bon voilà
c'est pas le sujet par contre donc c'est
fini
sauf que c'est pas fini parce qu'il ya
eu une petite galère je vais vous
raconter ça après si ça vous dérange pas
parce que là j'ai eu une anesthésie donc
bah je sais pas trop quoi faire avec ma
lèvre supérieure
j'ai l'impression d'être tue la passion
des tra bi malek temps on pouvait bien
drap se dit c'est tout ça se réveiller
un petit peu et je reviens vers vous
asap
voilà ça y est mon visage c'est un petit
peu rêver j'ai donc je peux vous
raconter ce qui s'est passé en fait
alors voilà une bonne nouvelle c'est que
ma couronne ramadan celle qui était la
plus qu'assez c'est nickel voilà elle me
la poser la bombe il reste un petit peu
de un petit peu de ciment autour ça va
partir au fur et à mesure mais celle là
c'est bon c'est du définitif
l'autre en revanche la facette
il ya eu un petit souci c'est à dire que
le prothésiste tabac a pas fait la bonne
une forme donc ça se voit pas beaucoup
comme ça mais en vrai elle s'ajuste
balle il a notamment petit jour sur le
côté là qui potentiellement peut laisser
passer des trucs avec le risque de
l'infection et c'est donc pas pas top
a priori de ce que j'ai compris il ya eu
un problème notamment probablement une
petite bulle au moment du moulage qui
c'est qui s'est pété donc il ya un
espace qui devrait pas exister
donc il faut que j'y retourne dans une
semaine on m'a repris des emprunts pour
faire un nouveau moulage pour refaire
cette phase est alors là c'est celle qui
aura dû être définitive qu elle m'a posé
à peu monté pour une semaine ça pose sa
pose pas de souci donc ça ressemble un
peu à quelque chose c'est que ça
commence à être pas trop mal mais bon
faut quand même que j'y retourne qu'elle
me l'enlève et qu'elle me met une vraie
qui lui a bien su s'ajuster
là le souci principal
en plus d'être un petit peu une
esthétique et que là il ya un petit jour
c'est que elle m'a pas mis la même le
même simon l'anem colle pour celle là
et pour celles là parce que celle là
c'est de la colle provisoire du câble a
retiré la semaine prochaine à l'ap a
accroché sa commune bourrine et il se
trouve que les deux cols n'ont pas tout
à fait la même
la même couleur et que comme celle ci
c'est juste une facette elle est fine
donc du convoi un peu la couleur de la
colle à travers si tu fais que c'est pas
tout à fait la même teinte
elle a pris une teinte qui ressemble au
reste de 2 mai dans là ça fait c'est pas
tout à fait ça donc c'est un contretemps
je pense en avoir fini aujourd'hui on
n'est pas finie aujourd'hui il faut que
j'y retourne dans une semaine en
espérant que tout va bien se passer
voilà donc je vous donne rendez-vous
dans une semaine sauf si d'ici là sa
tête ou quoi que ce soit que pour des
raisons x ou y je dois y retourner
voilà donc à bientôt à dans une semaine
voilà voilà ça fait déjà une semaine
donc aujourd'hui le programme c'est
qu'on le change la face est là qui a été
mal le mal réalisée par le prothésiste
donc je sais pas à trop j'imagine que je
vais avoir une anesthésie encore mais je
suis pas sûr de toute façon bas comme
d'hab je reviens après vous vous
raconter tout ça et vous pouvez croiser
les doigts pour moi on espère que c'est
le dernier rendez vous aujourd'hui
normalement ça aurait dû être le dernier
rendez vous la semaine dernière de là
donc je le vend pas la peau de l'ours
mais voilà bon à taez
alors j'ai deux nouvelles une bonne et
une bonne la bonne c'est que le gp2
esthétique donc je parle normalement et
que c'est très agréable
le sapin a été douloureux la bonne c'est
que ça y est c'est fini voilà on est on
est au bout du chemin
alors avant que de discutailler je vous
montre
[Musique]
voilà donc les deux sont définitives la
couronne de la dernière fois la prothèse
de couronnes dentaires je suis beaucoup
trop près et la face est définitive
cette fois parce que pas de cas de
défaut de fabrication donc donc c'est
cool ça a été très vite mis son espèce
de petit pied de biche sur lequel elle
tape comme ça pour faire sauter le la
dans provisoire elle m'a tout bien rené
toyer tout est un repos lille pour tous
soit soit clean la marque remisera un
additif et elle a placé la place et la
facette tout tient très bien il n'y a
pas de souci petit truc c'est quand même
assez particulier de surtout et des
dents qui sont pas les siennes pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que c'est pas
complètement les mêmes sensations 1,38
touche où donc est à toi et qu'en tu
touches une banque n'est pas à toi c'est
pas pareil
et ensuite parce que c'est pas forcément
exactement le même la même disposition
que l'initiale mans moi par exemple
celle là était un peu décalé comme ça
ils en ont profité pour la la remettre
dans l'axé
donc j'ai une sensation différente
d'avant et puis aussi là comme j'ai ici
une prothèse de couronnes dentaires
complète ici juste une facette derrière
les deux dents sont pas complètement
dans le même dans le même état donc par
exemple derrière celle là je sens des
trucs que je ne sentais pas avant du
coup il faut vraiment le temps que je me
réhabitue parce que je parle pas tout à
fait comme avant parce que j'ai tendance
à
jouer avec les petits qui te disant
perfection que j'avais pas avant match
le stade faut quand même je pense qu'on
fait un petit temps d'adaptation
là pour l'immédiat ce qui se passe c'est
que pendant 48 heures je n'y crois
toujours pas avec celle là le temps
qu'elles soient bien bien accroché et
puis ensuite je continue ma vie comme si
rien ne s'était passé j'ai des dents qui
sont qui sont classique et normale
ce que je vais faire maintenant vous
savez tout ça c'est que je vais manger
parce que j'ai faim et puis on se revoit
un petit peu plus tard pour faire un
petit bilan sous forme de conseils
si vous devez vous refaire les dents
voilà melty tips tiré de mon expérience
personnelle à plus
non ecoutez-le fort de cette petite
expérience à riche en enseignements je
vais vous donner maintenant mes petits
conseils perso si jamais un jour vous
aviez besoin de vous faire refaire les
dents
c'est là avant les rendez vous
renseignez vous auprès de votre mutuelle
demander un devis à votre dentiste
envoyé sa la mutuelle pour savoir
combien ils vont prendre en charge ou
alors si vous êtes vraiment très près
ses bas vous payez tout et vous envoyer
la facture après les soins mais
renseigne en tant que vous allez dans le
casser ne mangez pas dessus ne croyez
pas avec 6 et les dents de devant ne
marchait pas avec qui sait les dents du
côté voilà ne vous en servez pas brosser
vaut donc qui sont saines
c'est à dire celles qui sont pas cassés
mais brossé par celles qui sont cassés
par contre ce que vous pouvez faire pour
remplacer pour compenser un peu le truc
c'est vous faire des bains de bouche
vous allez chez votre pharmacien vous
expliquer la situation il va vous donner
ce qu'il faut éviter de trop toucher les
dents cassées laissez les tranquille
juste avant les rendez-vous manger avant
d'aller chez le dentiste ainsi c'est à
peu près leur dard pas parce que après
que ça risque d'être un petit peu
compliqué pensez à vous brosser les
dents pour que ce soit propre
alors les dents pas cassé et puis bah
éventuellement comme on l'a dit vous
faites un petit bain de bouche si besoin
est petite astuce apprenez une pastille
à la vente parce que votre dentiste vous
allez en avoir besoin il va vous rendre
des services
c'est mieux de pas lui balancer votre
votre haleine de panda mort au visage
oubliez pas que vous allez avoir
beaucoup besoin de respirer par le nez
parce que du côté de la bouche ça risque
d'être un petit peu pris donc si vous
voulez pas étouffé pendant par exemple
qui vous prennent les empreintes
dentaires
prenez des mouchoirs si vous êtes
enrhumé par exemple et mouche et vous
juste avant le rendez vous ou alors vous
pouvez même vous faire un outil la hache
données avant de partir et puis il a
fait pipi avant d'y aller que parce que
ça peut être un peu long
on sait la mettre deux fois une petite
douleur petit sursaut et c'est le drame
pendant le rendez vous ben là c'est un
peu compliqué un peu déjà plus grand
chose à faire mais pas éventuellement
penser à des trucs cool et effet pas
trop vous focaliser sur ce qui est en
train de se passer dans votre bouche a
laissé libre cours à votre imagination
à la fin de la séance n'hésitez pas à
poser des questions sur la suite des
événements ou à dire s'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas ou a réclamé un truc si
vous avez besoin de quelque chose
moi par exemple si j'avais pas réclamé
je n'aurais pas eu de trucs temporaire
sera resté avec mes dents mais dans ce
cas c'est ce qui va embêter
et puis parler au dernier rendez vous il
y avait des trucs qui me coupe est un
peu derrière que l'attentiste avait pas
forcément lieu mais que moi je le
sentais j'ai demandé à ce qu'elle les
limes un peu et elle l'a fait mais
n'hésitez surtout pas à poser des
questions ou à réclamer si vous avez
besoin de quelque chose entre deux
rendez vous n'attendez pas d'avoir mal
pour prendre vos médicaments contre la
douleur ça marche bien comme ça mangez
pas sur vos dents provisoire parce que
c'est toujours moins bien fixé est un
peu plus fragile que des dents
définitives donc essayer d'éviter les
trucs trop durs ou les trucs où il faut
vraiment croquer parce que c'est pas
toujours facile d'éviter de s'en servir
et toujours pareil pour le brossage des
dents vous brosser les dents saines vous
tripoter pas trop elle est d'en réparer
toit sont provisoires et vous pouvez
continuer les bains de bouche après les
rendez vous toujours pareil avec les
médicaments contre la douleur
les antalgiques comme on dit dans le
jargon si vous en avez besoin
attendez pas d'avoir mal prenez les
systématiquement au moins pendant un
jour ou deux mangez pas sur vos dents
définitives pendant le temps que vous
aura donné votre dentiste et 6
il ou elle oublie de vous le dire poser
la question moi par exemple c'était 48
heures mais c'est toujours pareil
n'oubliez pas d'envoyer votre facture à
votre mutuelle si vous voulez être
remboursés c'est bien et puis surtout
s'il ya un souci
quoi que ce soit une douleur quelque
chose qui bouge une sensation
désagréable vous appelez votre dentiste
et éventuellement vous reprenez rendez
vous pour aller faire check et où sa
voie l'amour en vrai jespere que vous
aurez jamais besoin de tous ses conseils
mais ben ça peut arriver quand même donc
voilà ces cadeaux je vous le donne en
attendant dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]